He is the author of one of the
best-selling business book series of all
time:
Rich dad poor dad. For the past several
years he's been a huge supporter of the
network marketing industry.
He's made the claim that network
marketing is the E-business of the 21st
century. Mentor me Robert!
Let me tell you, why I endorsed network
marketing, why I call it the power of it.
The reason for this, as an
entrepreneur, this word here
network marketing is the key to making a
lot of money to being successful.
It's only those people who have an
employee mentality working for a
pay-check, or like a specialist, or small
business guy just wants it for
themselves. They don't understand the
power of network marketing.
Let me give it. This is not just for the
network marketing industry. You know when
you talk about television stations, they
talk about a television, net-work
That's how big people think. They think in terms of networks.
When you talk about radio, they talk
about a radio network. And the same
thing
my friend owns a series of gas stations.  He calls it a network of gas stations
So the rich use the term network a lot.
And I know one of the reasons when I
started in endorsed network marketing is
because in many circles
it has a negative connotation. And that's
because a lot of times people shouldn't
be in the business, join the business or
also people abused of business. But the
reason I endorsed network marketing is
for people who really want to get out of
the rat race and really want to get on
with you know building a business by
helping other people build their
businesses.
So that's why I endorsed network
marketing. Another reason I endorse it is,
because network marketing will give you
the sales skills of the communication
skills or the self esteem and the
emotional courage to go and knock on
doors and talk to other people.
If you don't have that courage, or you're
more afraid of what somebody else thinks
of you, you'll probably never be
successful in network marketing, but
you'll probably never be successful in
business anyway. So I love network
marketing, because network marketing
take an average person like me, or John
and actually work with you and build you
up. So you have a personal courage to
take the knows to take the rejection do
not really care what you do care what
other people think of you. It's the
reason people are not successful. They
want to follow the herd and do what
everybody else does. And ninety percent
that people on this earth when it comes
to money our financial losers.
So if you're going to become successful
you could not care with the foundering
world does.
You really had a breakaway, my rich dad
call about 90 10 rule. That meant ten
percent of the people make ninety
percent of money. And ninety percent of
people make ten percent of the money.
So the beauty of network marketing
there's no guarantees, but it gives you
the opportunity to be in that ten
percent. And the way you get in that ten
percent is to find that person inside of
you, who cares more of what you think
about yourself. Then you care what other
people think of you.
So the beauty of network marketing is it
gives people the courage sales skills
and communication skills to be a leader.
And that's what it takes to be
successful in world is to be a leader. As
an entrepreneur
I have built many businesses from
scratch. And as somebody should know one
of them crashed also.
Statistics show that most new businesses
fail within the first five years.
Ninety percent in fact. That the ten
percent that survived the the roof
remaining temples that crash in the
second five years.So long as most are
gone in ten years. So i looked at many
different models and one that stands out
for me is network marketing. And the
reason for that it takes very little
upfront cash is low overhead.
If you can do it part time always keep
your daytime job, but do this part-time.
And once the business up and running it can generate enough income. So that you
can move from the left side to the right
side of the quadrant. So let me tell you
about my introduction of network
marketing. Because I had a very close
mind to it. Since I can build my own
businesses. I said why do I needed that
network marketing business? But about 15
years ago I have a good friend. His name
is Bill. And this guy is the best real
estate investor I know. He has tons of
assets in here. So I said: Bill! Why did
you start a network marketing business?
And is simple. Sense was very simple.
He says, it's my way of helping people.
But more importantly he says the reason.
Most people can't invest in real estate
this, because they don't have a business.
They don't make enough money. Simply because taxes debt inflation retirement
savings. They kill them. They cannot even invest. So my friend Bill, who is a
professional real estate entrepreneurs, he says
i started a network marketing
business.
So the people that worked with me could
start their own business and then invest
money with him.
So with that I realized then that
network marketing wasn't about making
money. But it was about helping people to help other people make money so they
become financially free.
So the beauty of network marketing I
said like it's very low entry point
doesn't take much money you can do it part time. And where you profit is in most big
corporations as they spend millions
sometimes billions of dollars in
advertising.
So rather they give that money to
advertisers. Network market depends on
building a network is called word of
mouth like you recommend a movie to a
best friend.
So really the reason I support network
marketing because it's not about selling.
It's about people helping people build
assets in the acid columns. Becoming
business owners and then becoming
investors. Rather than going through all
of this here, which most easy assets go through. In this section I want to talk
to you about a different kind of
quadrant. Years ago I found out there was
four kinds of people in the world.
You know. One type are people who must be right.
These people know all the right answers.They went to school. They know everything.
You can't tell them anything.
This is not a good business for them.
Because their minds are to set. Another
kind of person is a person who must be
comfortable. You know. The house could be
on fire, but they're still watching TV.
You know eating a hot dog watching
what's going on the world.
These people are toast. Because the world
economy is not coming back the early
world economy has moved on. And people
who need to be comfortable will probably
be left behind.
So the people who might you need to be
comfortable it probably shouldn't talk
to them, because you only make them
uncomfortable. And they're probably not
going to make the move, because number
one priority is being comfortable.
Another kind of person is a person who
must be light.
You know. They want to please everybody.
This is probably not the business for
them either.
You know, because they want somebody
else's approval.
They want to be the good little boy or
girl say: I did the right thing that I
you like me. Don't you?
And so they probably not
be successful the 21st century, Because
they'll probably want to be a light day
people have to be right. And people want to
be comfortable. All right! Could be
comfortable.
All right! You're very right. You know
that's part of being light. But! The
business for the people of the 21st
century are people who must win. And
that's where I am at. One of the best
things I was taught in the Marine Corps
in military school.
It's not how many times you get knocked
down. It's how many times you stand up.
When somebody knocks you back. What do
you do? Oh, you hurt my feelings!
You will probably not be successful . The
world will probably pass you by.
Because as I said the world economy is
moved on. It's not coming back.
So, winners will win, but winning takes
sacrifice. Success takes sacrifice. And
these are the people who will do best in
business of the 21st century.
So, when you're talking to people, you
know, about this business, you have to
look at him and ask yourself: is this
person really just going to be like.
They'll tell you what you want to hear.
Or they're going to argue with you,
because they know all the right answers.
Are they going to get very upset with you for disturbing them.
So what you're looking for the network
marketing business are people who want
to win.
People who know the economy has moved on.
You'll find every race gender age and
background in network marketing. But what
they really want to do is they want to
win. It really is a true playing field in
the world. But not for these people. These
people will left behind.
Network Marketing is for people want a win.
Because network marketing is the
business model of the future. If you want
the government to take care of you, then
just keep doing what you want to do. It
is possible for everyone to win. But the
problem is you've got to commit to it.
You've got to say this is what I'm going
to do. I'm going to dedicate five years
of my life.
Well look at the leaders to say: those
are people who want to be like. Those are
the kinds of people I want to hang out
with.
That's what you got to say to yourself.
Well as we know there's fewer and fewer
jobs in American corporations say
they're hiring. But they're not hiring in
America the hiring overseas. But more
than that is that there is I endorse
network marketing is most people are
addicted to the paycheck. The paycheck is
one of the most sinister plots ever pull
upon a human being.
If you need a paycheck you've sold your
soul. You know you sold your body, your
mind, your spirit and your emotions. You
sit there in fear of losing your job. Or
can I get a raise? Or you know will I get
promoted.
I mean and then, and then why would you
do that?
Another thing about with we endorse
network marketing, we don't think of it
as a network marketing. We think of it as
entrepreneur development. Because if you
need a paycheck,
this is not your business. You know we
build businesses. So sometimes when Kim
and I do a deal we may not receive a
paycheck for 5-6 years. You know and so
these guys come: oh, we never get rich quick!
You know and some people do. I don't know
if you do or not, but that is an employee,
get rich,
loser mindset. And so the thing that
network marketing does is really going
to cure you of that loser paycheck,
get-rich-quick mentality and actually
build a business. You know we build
businesses,
but and that's how we're rich. But we
don't get rich quick and I don't need a
paycheck. I never want a paycheck. So
that's kind of a revolutionary thought
to most people up there, who went to
school to get good grades and get a job.
You know they get a high-paying job at
them.
The higher paying job you, you pay higher
taxes and you wonder why you never get
ahead.
That's because you went to school to get
a job and a paycheck.
You've got to get away from the paycheck
and sometimes it might take 2-3 years
ago away from that. And that's what
network marketing teaches people.
it's an entrepreneurs mindset. As an
entrepreneur spirit.
Not all lose our employee and a paycheck mentality.
Thank you guys so much for watching. I'd
love to know what you think of this
video. What you think about network
marketing if you learn from it.
Leave in the comments below. I'll join
the discussion. My goal with this channel
7 million subscribers so. Anything he did
how spread the video share with friends,
posted on Twitter,
I really really appreciate it. Thank you
guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe. I'll see you soon.